Hey guys,
We need your help.
We need good video editors.
So if you are a good video editor
and you want to help us to share the Gospel
effectively to all people in all nations,
then please reach out to us especially if you're a
mature Christian, because it does help you to edit
the videos better because you understand the Word.
Of course we're not going to know everything
because we're all growing in Christ, but if
you pray about it and you know this is what
God wants you to do, then please reach out
to us and use your skills for God's glory.
Reach out to us today.
If your editing is really good,
if God has blessed you with creativity and
speed and effectiveness to share His gospel
in a different way, we need you.
Reach out to us today.